originaire de Toulouse Marie-Noëlle
Fontan a longtemps vécu au Guatemala
avant de s'installer à Paris sa nouvelle
exposition est à l'image de sa vie entre
Europe et Amérique centrale Marie-Noëlle
a tissé des fils chez ma mère et qui
sait en fait qui nous faisait le
vêtements et donc quand on est enfant on
copie on copie les parents voilà
et elle au lieu de faire du tricot elle
tisser et donc moi j'ai fait pareil
pareil pas tout à fait puisque
Marie-Noëlle expérimente amoureuse des
plantes elle collecte les végétaux
qu'elle trouve en France au Mexique au
Guatemala pour les incorporer au fil
alors du Yuka il y en a en France parce
qu'on en trouve dans les appartements
mais ce Yuka que je trouve c'est c'est
tropical
en fait il y en a beaucoup qui viennent
du Salvador et le Salvador la plante
nationale du Salvador c'est le yucca
Jacques Plante est une découverte mais
pour une bonne manipulation toute
doivent être suffisamment longue sans
s'avérer trop lisse Marie-Noëlle
travaille le fil et le végétal feuille
racine ou écorce se mêlentissage ses
créations étonnantes rappellent tantôt
des insectes tantôt des lianes des
lianes faisant écho à des racines
filmées par le salvadorien Guillermo
escalone est mise en musique par le
guatemaltèque igorde et Gan Daria racine
aérienne pour une ambiance tropicale où
la nature est omniprésente jamais tissé
beaucoup là-bas mais tout n'est pas trop
piquant non c'est juste l'idée
Marie-Noëlle conjugue ainsi exotisme et
local ça c'est du boulot
là-bas c'est du lin que l'on trouve en
Normandie les racines aériennes sont à
découvrir en entrée libre à l’écu de
France à Viroflay jusqu'au 18 octobre
Marie-Noëlle Fontan sera régulièrement
présente sur le site l'occasion pour les
visiteurs d'échanger avec l'artiste